[music]
[applause]
welcome to the interview with
christian lindner, top candidate of the
free democrats for the general election,
nice
to have you here, thank you very much for the invitation,
welcome and only a matter for the countries with
experience, let's talk about afghanistan
tens of thousands of people in afghanistan are always waiting
they fear
for their lives urgently want to
leave the country that is now being ruled by the taliban
what can germany do
and above all what must germany
do immediately to help these people
we must help those who in the
past  have worked loyally for the german
state for years are also
looking for talks with the new rulers these talks are also
there to enable people to leave the country for humanitarian reasons
we owe the so-called local staff
our moral obligation
and i very much regret that it didn’t
work out in  the past few months
in good time e  to
enable an evacuation and there are
certainly many others who are now on
the run because they fear that
they will not be able to lead a life in
freedom here there should be a
special summit of the head of
government and heads of the eu
for a common afghanistan
policy  decent accommodation is also possible in the immediate
vicinity of the country
, but that
doesn't take very long if you
first have to wait for a summit, then have to make
decisions, etc. the people
who are still there are afraid for their lives
, so you have to agree, that's why there would have
been such a special summit a long time ago
must give further delay does not
make sense the refugee agency of the
united nations must now be
equipped with everything that is
necessary that now has a high priority
incidentally also the otherwise necessary
support economic
support for the neighboring states of
afghanistan on the now
possibly
there may be a big task
why has
n't it happened yet why are we
letting the afghan men and women down
this question would of course be of the
german federal government
they didn't pay any systematic
attention to the deployment and
the situation in afghanistan
was able to see this very clearly at one point
during the last
government
declaration on afghanistan, the chancellor asked a series of
questions about self-supporting
security structures, a political
process and so on, and it is precisely these
questions that we in the parliamentary opposition have asked in the past
over the past few years
been asked again and again uni wants to be
fair by saying that from the colleagues in
the green group as well as from us in the
liberal faction, but quite
obviously the government has paid too
little attention to the situation and therefore
did not make it concrete in good time
where li  egt the mistake i'm in
contact with people who are on site it
's a matter of life and death for several
weeks we've only been talking hundreds have
they created mr what's going on where's
the mistake
chancellery foreign ministry and our
defense ministry don't talk to each other
systematically we have to  so
also create other structures in germany for the future
i am
convinced we need something like
a federal security council where the
resources active in foreign policy can
also coordinate institutionally
exchange data at the highest level and i
would also like the ministry in addition to the ministries i just mentioned
to be accepted for economic development
imagine there was an intention
that economic cooperation
with neighboring states of
afghanistan should be stopped
only those who quite
obviously misjudged the situation in
afghanistan can come up with such a project  t
did you also see a mistake with the
chancellor directly the
chancellor has the authority to set
guidelines the chancellor
is of
course ultimately
responsible for her own house the
chancellery also coordinates our
intelligence services and my
impression is that chancellor
merkel never considered this mission in afghanistan hers
but she
inherited it politically,
so to speak, and therefore did not pay enough
attention my thing
alone has to ask the question when
ms merkel was last in afghanistan did
she get involved in the political process in
doha which has been in the last few
months and years  given that she
got involved herself, as
one might have expected at least in retrospect
, given the fact
that Germany was the second largest
provider of troops in the end,
you also talk about the
possibility that the neighboring
countries should help d  as well as people who
live in afghanistan could also flee there
what do you mean exactly and which
neighboring countries all neighboring
neighboring countries patient as pakistan
uzbekistan for example the viruses
would have to remain so to speak
this question has to be asked later
but now it can be
asked later the clock only stops  so i
can tell you the years
later should be asked we should say it will
be different with the situation in
syria the situation is not one to one
comparable 2015 and nevertheless
we should learn the lessons from the situation in syria
20.15 we should people who
on the  refugees cannot be expected to have to travel the
long and dangerous route to
europe and
therefore there must be
a first possibility of
decent accommodation in the immediate vicinity if this
is secured then the
refugee agency of the united
nations can check the international organization
for migration
w  what needs to be done is a
return to
afghanistan possible in the medium term is it
probably possible if not which
states are willing to accept contingents in the sense of
a resettlement first of
all acute human suffering must be
prevented then wait and see if the
neighboring countries
want to take in afghan refugees  wait and
see you have the word
human dignity i that is
important for you but when we look around
and reporters without borders
freedom of the press is concerned pakistan
turkmenistan
tajikistan uzbekistan iran china are at the bottom when we
also look at the democracy index
which is done before the economy it is
pakistan on hands carried a chimney is
162 out of 167 these are authoritarian regimes
how is that supposed to take place is
it humane that the people
live there when you know it already people have
fled there they suffer
there too why not to germany
after the international  it is international
law when it comes to the question of fleeing,
so the model is that protection is suitable for refugees as close as possible
to their old homeland
i
think that is responsible from the point of view that
there is now basic
support,
especially if so
the united
nations refugee agency  he is responsible for
accommodation in a neighboring town mr
lindner in 2015 germany took in
hundreds of thousands of refugees from syria
from the civil war
zone the chancellor said at the time
we can do it why ca
n’t we take in 10,000 refugees from afghanistan this time
and you have to
differentiate between two things
about 10,000  accepting local staff and their
relatives you have to
differentiate this from a flight movement
of people who set off as members of a
group we
have to see that on the one hand there is
individual persecution because someone, for
example, with the German  state has
worked together there
might even be a question of whether that
would be a reason for asylum asylum in
German law always means individually
persecuted while fleeing is a
movement that takes place because someone, as a
member of a group, starts moving because of
a civil war or a
natural disaster
that is legal  to be distinguished
from each other and i am very much in favor of
germany fulfilling its
humanitarian obligations but in an
orderly way qualified
immigration asylum
humanitarian protection for people on the
run these are 3 different
we take in what do you estimate how many
afghan refugees or
asylum seekers i don’t want that in either
make the wise as the
austrian chancellor short who
said yes directly there is no
recording such solo efforts as from
mr short i think wrong vice versa
it would not
be right if germany for its part with
a number the  we call
going it alone power therefore i plead
for a common european
afghanistan policy to describe the
debate about the additional admission of
refugees is being discussed here
but also worldwide international
our viewers are also interested in it
and that is why we are now getting a viewer question
from syria
[music  ]
with the f10 every minute is as great as alemannia is
always stronger
than alemannia has been so far after three
years it's never be like that -
aha de la torre lr heiko fischer
[music]
your answer yes germany has a
humanitarian obligation we  respect
our right to
asylum very highly, this is also a sign of
our international responsibility,
but there must be an orderly, common
European policy, no
German special path, and the goal must
always be that as soon as possible,
people in the old homeland can take part in the
stabilization and then
rebuilding, we can go to
example yes not i  n germany
taking in all elite foreigners would
mean that there
are no development prospects for society there but it is
not about your dearest child people who
are fighting for their lives and the refugees are
not going to germany and to
europe because they just
want to come by but it works  to life and death
yes unwanted advertising the
seriousness of the situation is very high
that is exactly like 23 10 214 I
also have about syrian refugees
but at the beginning it was discussed for
well you won’t get here it looks
like that according to experts that that  what will
also happen with the afghan refugees
we are prepared for
people to come here why
don't we react now and take people in
immediately now and today i believe
that germany has lived up to its responsibility in recent
years compared to other
european societies and
i ask  the question right  en when we
ask about an international task
and talk about resettlement that is
what is behind your word
actually systematic recording then
one has to ask what
responsibility the united states of
america actually have either about germany
which but then about germany
germany has to put itself in a
insert international community in
2005, in our
opinion, germany had a special path and
we should not repeat this path from 2015 as a lesson from
the time seven years ago or a good
seven years ago, but now
we must find a common international
answer to people in need  to
help he lived the protection of
human rights is a priority for your party
how can you then do business with countries
such as saudi arabia or iran
is that okay
difficult there are of course
many, many countries in the world that meet our demands of
our self demands on
people  right-wing democracy and the
rule of law do not correspond to respect for
international law and
multilateralism and
therefore, on the other hand, as a realist, one has to
recognize that there are
different degrees of
cooperation, there is exchange
and trade, the
possibility of people from other countries entering the country
, then there are alliances and it  there is
also the possibility that there is no
exchange at all and between these
variants between these variants
you have to decide in each case which
category it is in but
human rights should still have
priority yes but that would mean, for
example, if we only used everything from
our human rights  make the standard
dependent that we ourselves
would have a problem with the usa because they still have
the death penalty there so it is
always necessary to see one's own claims in practice,
to insist on them
and, for example, to stick to the example of the
usa
it would be more appropriate not only in saudi arabia but in
china to conduct civil society dialogue
on such issues and
still
enable cooperation to varying degrees to
varying degrees means that with
canada it’s different than with china
it’s different with turkey than with
saudi arabia we are
we also have a question from the audience from hong kong you addressed it yourself we once asked
what the audience wanted
[music]
such a question again a
determined and less involved politics
than what we have experienced in the past few
years from ms merkel and her
governments i was  I was
in Hong Kong myself before the 2009 pandemic 10 and
I also had contact with representatives
of the democratic opposition at the time
and I was in Beijing afterwards and also spoke
to officials from the CP
who, by the way, were not impressed and
to say it politely that we
were in Hong Kong before  afterwards in
beijing and in these talks ha  when
we
addressed the human rights situation i think that's exactly how
you have to do it what do you say so what do
you then demand compliance with
international law
especially with regard to hong kong there were
clear promises that have been broken but
that has to be addressed at every opportunity
at the political
level  also in
civil society and
economic contacts i also want to
name a concrete consequence a
state like and the people's republic of
china which breaks international law which
does not
meet the minimum standards that we have to have when it comes to human rights
which, by the way, also in the area of
world trade is downright imperial, also sometimes
appearing with dumping
there can be no more for such a state. the
current agreement between the european
union and the people's republic of china
should therefore not
be ratified  gste trading partners with
with germany is that is so that is
so that is what should be changed
there and the automotive industry is
completely dependent on china but the
german automobiles are so good that
i do not fear blackmail
so it can
not be a discount for commercial interests with
human rights or with
international law and therefore the agreement that the
european union intends to conclude with the people's
republic of china does
not meet our requirements this has to
be discussed
again for various reasons i believe that there is a
chance with the administration of
mr both that the global west where
we have different interests  but
we do have common values ​​that we
have to respond to the challenge of china
at the same time as a
trading partner and system
competitor that we have to respond together
but germany is
the most important trading partner for china
in the european union we do
risky business  but still not if
we insist on human rights and fair
world trade if we
keep reminding ourselves of international law that
we would sell less because we have
good products that are sought after on the
chinese market and so
i can't imagine that
if we insist on human rights
on  exist under international law that is
trade restrictions, for example from the
chinese side if it were to be said in the
subjunctive then one would have to
accept it let's talk about russia
russia is a difficult region of
the world first of all it wasn't
chosen that's the situation at the
moment yes the situation in russia  after
the annexation of crimea and sevastopol, there were
sanctions, european sanctions
against russia, which are now valid
until the end of june
2022, how sensible and how efficient are
such sanctions, is this the right
measure to put pressure on russia with
russia,
there must be sanctions and the
sanctions  the  exist now must
also be continued because otherwise the
principle would give the wrong signal,
but i believe that the pressure should also be applied in a more
targeted manner in my
talks with the liberal opposition
from russia, for example during
his stay in berlin with
mr navalny and others  i learned one thing
we need to meet the
supporters of the
putin system individually,
we as free democrats have
always campaigned for so-called magnitsky legislation i.e.
individual sanctions
travel restrictions
children who cannot go to foreign
schools no property no
accounts abroad for the supporters
of the putin system  that seems to be more
accurate than
adopting sanctions new k which then
hit the russian people and in case of doubt mr
putin even allow himself
to be portrayed as a victim you talk
about sanctions you also have that c&
a four years ago when we
interviewed us here  t you
have also told them how important sanctions
are after four years we are noticing that
crimea is still where it is and because it is
under the control of
russia not that much has changed what needs to
happen concretely so that the
situation on the ground changes  ends what do you demand the
crimea will be the last topic that
we can solve because that is a
symbolic conflict we have many
other topics before that russia's attempts
to influence western
democracies
the
threat scenarios vis-à-vis the
baltic states and eastern europe, for example, the
retrofitting of nuclear-
equipped land-based medium-haul routes in violation of the treaty
through ukraine don't like to hear if
you say crimea will be the last
then you would have understood what i
mean okay we also have a question from
a viewer from russia
maybe we'll hear what the question is
[music]
yes that is underlines itself  and how
can you with russia and how should you
with  russia did business
given the circumstances you just
described if russia changes its
policy is cooperative again
stops the gestures of dominance stops the
threat to ukraine for example
ends then we can talk
about improving relations again
i think it would be great we could
talk about  Greater travel freedoms
and maybe even a
trade agreement, but at the moment
we are so far
away from that that at the moment, I would
say symbolically, as long as Mr. Navalny is
still in prison under these
conditions, we have to do more, as we demand,
with stronger sanctions in the Magnitsky
system  so
talk about individually effective sanctions than about an
improvement in
economic relations, much as i regret that, because good
common relations in the house
of europe that would be advantageous both for the
russian people and for the
european union but the prerequisite
for us in the house
Europe cooperating with each other again is that
Russia sticks to the rules of the house
rules I would be
interested in you again on the subject of crime novels and
Ukraine what should happen specifically
if that were the priority you said
that is now if you see them a
bit didn't misunderstand
i said if you see what the
threat is and that russia is
even retrofitting nuclear weapons, then
the first thing will be that we
hold disarmament talks again, that the
threatening gestures towards the baltic states
end, that the illegal border crossings
in eastern ukraine end here and now
and to kiel  only then will be the last thing
will be that russia steers in
the crimea but specifically crimea what
demand do you see it differently no well
no but that's why i
'm not in the government we need
a process so our
determination will make clear
magnitsky legislation  magnitsky
sanctions now and why do they have them
so far not been
able to assert yourself with this demand what kind of
resistance is there this question should be addressed to the
government and especially
to mrs merkel we
applied for
this in the german federal parliament as the first first faction the reason was the
assassination attempt on mr navalny and
unfortunately this is the case  line has
not yet been adopted by the federal
government but you will in a future
federal government if you are involved in ensuring
that we enforce this if you
just state it or will you
make it a condition
i am not in a
position to make all the political content of
the fdp a condition of a  government has to
do that i can only say it is
a very serious concern of the fdp
we have documented that and i am
actually in good spirits that we
can find supporters for it if
foreign policy is now
subjected to another critical review partner you
would the am  most likely find
think we in  this question with the
colleagues from alliance 90
the greens are close together
union and spd have
others in my impression also very strongly
influenced by energy policy
considerations
slowly i know so that you don't
misunderstand me nord stream two is also
important from our point of view  there is
a difference if i may add
that the difference between us is
we want the infrastructure nord stream
2 but we have always advocated
making it a european
project in coordination with our
neighbors it is not just a
purely private project the
woman  merkel said and on the other hand
the interests of ukraine
must be taken into account and not only
with a deal that makes money but
the institutional is ruled out
that russia can project
blackmail scenarios onto ukraine with gas deliveries
slowly coming to the end i have
a short question too  the time of
federal chancellor angela merkel is also coming
to an end after 16 years as federal chancellor
what do you remember most about angela
merkel high level of personal commitment she put her
intellectual gifts and her entire
capacity in the service of our
state that deserves great
recognition in terms of the political balance sheet
should objective minds other than
me be open